I really want to say thank you to my son
and the mother of my son for making me
believe in people again and things being
possible so thank you I couldn't be here
without Atlanta like and I really want
to thank the migos not for being in the
show but for making bad and bougie like
that's the best song ever so um what
made you shout out to me goes ah because
you heard there were some people in
there oh confused just awesome like a
little bit I don't know I I love the me
goes like I think they're awesome I
think they're the Beatles well a guy I
mean that song is just amazing have you
heard that song course I have exactly
like it's the best song man but what
does this mean to take over these two
Golden Globes man I mean hopefully
season 3 you make something super
personal and specific you'll you'll
reach a wide group of people and I think
the show is also authentic you know
they're like real very out-there people
gotta be real right now yeah I think
we've realized that like from what's
happening in this country all over the
world small talk about things is not
getting us anything we want so you've
got to be honest about it and you have
to be willing to listen to each other so
I think this show kind of is playing
around with that
[Music]
you
[Music]
you